hi guys i'm cindy sweeney and i play
pippa in the foyers and i'm here with
buzzfeed to answer 30 questions
[Music]
what did you have for breakfast berries
how many hours of sleep did you get last
night what has been the best part of
your day so far my dog's here
what's a song that always puts you in a
good mood vacation by dirty hats i love
my occupation hey hey hey
i'm on vacation it's a good day
yeah i like that song
three actors you want to start alongside
oh man angelina jolie meryl streep
jennifer lawrence describe your new
movie the voyeurs in three words thought
provoking
shocking
fun if your lawyer's poster justice
smith were an animal which would he be
he's so loving so i feel like he'd be
like a puppy of some sort pick one
co-star from the white lotus to be
stranded on an island jennifer coolidge
because she would keep every day
entertaining what do you think your
character from the white lotus is doing
right now olivia would be sitting in her
dorm room
scrolling through twitter who's at the
last euphoric co-star you texted with or
shared a meme mod and i sent each other
a lot of funny things
who was the last person
the last person i facetimed was my mom
last thing that you googled i googled is
mildew bad for you to ingest or like
smell
last tv show you binge watched sbu what
was your favorite show from your
childhood scooby doo it was the classic
one movie you'll never get sick of
watching crazy rich asians what was your
favorite thing about restoring your ford
broncos the learning process throughout
the entire journey i've learned
everything there possibly is i need
another celebrity you trade places with
for one day molly shannon she's a very
kind hilarious woman and i'd love to
just get to experience her life thoughts
on celebrities who don't date people
don't faith
i didn't know that was a thing who
should play you in a movie about your
life i hope that when there's a movie
about my life i'm a lot older and
there's a new person that no one knows
of that that plays me favorite character
you play i can't answer that every
character i love so dearly for different
reasons and hate them for different
reasons as well what do you think is the
most underrated piece of work from you i
think a lot of people forget that i was
in sharp objects what's another job you
think you'd be good at a good school
teacher i always had this dream of going
to different countries and and working
with children and sharing education and
trying to help just kids in any way i
can what's your most use emoji the
smiley face with the little hearts
around it the most used app on your
phone instagram what's your phone's
wallpaper
instagram i use instagram more i scroll
through tick tock
go to drink order i only drink water my
favorite ice cream flavor rainbow
sherbet that's your guilty pleasure
chick-fil-a chicken sandwiches
your biggest dating deal breaker if
they're consumed in their phone more
than their conversation with me what's
something that most people don't know
about you most people don't know that
i'm really shy and what advice would you
give to your young person i would love
to tell
little sid to not compare herself or
judge herself too harshly thank you guys
for watching i hope you all enjoy the
voyers on amazon prime and bye